busy news night welcome to Hannity at
this hour we are tracking huge multiple
big breaking stories on multiple fronts
we start tonight with a massive
development out of the Muller partisan
witch hunt tonight more evidence has
emerged that Bob Muller's 448 page
report was nothing but pure political
garbage full of errors put there
purposefully according to a brand-new
breaking story John Solomon some of the
very keys of Muller's assertions are
totally and provably false
for example the Muller report describes
Paul manna for its Ukrainian business
partner as a shady individual with ties
to Russian intelligence
now Muller wanted us all to believe that
the Trump campaign was essentially in
bed with a Russian spy but tonight
thanks to Solomon well we now know that
it is total BS and yeah you might want
to call it even Muller fake news now man
affords business partner was actually a
sensitive intelligence source for the US
State Department that's a big difference
so how and why did Muller and his team
purposely deceive you we the American
people now in fact he visited the u.s.
twice in 2016 to meet with State
Department officials and for years he
regularly met with the chief political
officer inside the US Embassy in Kiev
Muller had all the access to all this
information which means that he and his
merry band of all democratic donors no
Republican donors all Trump haters that
means they lied in that report and get
this Muller cast a dark shadow on this
individuals request to present a
Ukrainian peace plan to the Trump
campaign in 2016 but guess what John
Solomon discovered while he discovered
that the very same plan was presented to
the Obama administration the very same
year and Muller's team knew it now
Muller why would he print that Solomon
is not the first reporter now to raise
these concerns he will not be the last
now what this ends up being is outright
deception outright lying from Muller and
of course his Democratic
donar friends that he appointed now just
the latest and what is a very disturbing
pattern of lies misinformation character
assassination because remember on Monday
we first reported that Muller
deceptively edited a transcript from
former Trump attorney John Dowd who was
on this program and called that report
of fraud and during a privileged routine
call between attorneys remember they
originally had a joint defense agreement
while Muller conveniently omitted Daud
statement that his request for
communication was quote not only for the
president before the country and then he
was not asking for any confidential
information that exculpate Auriemma
dense was totally ripped out that is a
classic
Andrew Weissman Muller's pit bull his
tactic she may remember Cindy Powell's
book license to lie Weissman on multiple
occasions had withheld exculpatory
evidence in the past
why was he ever appointed and that's not
all let's not forget Muller's nine
minute long diatribe just last week when
the media got all ginned up and they
were full of hope and feel fear of hope
and and an anticipation that they
finally got the president well that
ended up being debunked a few hours
later because in fact for the DOJ policy
and ighting a sitting president was
never a consideration and Muller had
said that numerous times
so his press conference was an absolute
contradiction of everything he had said
and remember to joint statement hours
later the DOJ that means Attorney
General Barr the special counsels office
they were forced to totally walk back
and clarify the nine and a half minutes
that Muller was commenting and they
ended up reaffirming quote that the
special counsels report and his
statement today made clear that the
office concluded it would not reach a
determination one way or the other about
whether the president committed a crime
it had nothing to do with Justice
Department policy of whether you can or
cannot indict a sitting president in
other words everything mother said in
nine and a half minutes was false it was
phony it was fake it was innuendo an
attorney general bar pretty much bailed
him out and in that press conference he
really was begging Nadler
not to testify or be subpoenaed because
he knows that he has to answer questions
from Jim Jordan mark meadow meadows
devon newness will join us in a few
minutes he doesn't want any answer
questions like well mr. Muller when did
you know there was no collusion and when
you found out why didn't you and this
witch-hunt and by the way why did you
only hire hardcore Democratic donors
including former Hillary Clinton
attorney for the Clinton Foundation why
would you ever hire a guy like Andrew
Weissman who got tens of thousands of
Enron accounting execs fired and then
lost in the Supreme Court nine zero and
then had four Merrill executives put in
jail for a year and that was overturned
by the Fifth Circuit Court of Appeals
why we will appoint somebody like
Weissman known for atrocious conduct
actually attended Hillary Clinton's
so-called victory party on election
night didn't work out well so the
pattern is clear what we see now time
and time again the Special Counsel
manipulates information to unjustly
impugn a duly elected president of the
United States and by the way if Muller
had time for taxi medallions and loan
applications and ferrah violations and
such and so forth why didn't he have
time for the dirty Russian dossier that
Hillary Clinton paid for that's full of
Russian lies and disinformation
that actually was used to influence the
American people no excuse for that
there was no collusion there was no
obstruction and the Trump campaigns part
there was no conspiracy all the Trump
haters on Muller's team well they just
reverted to plan B that's a 448 page
smear campaign
they created a document definitely
intended to fuel even more lies more
conspiracy theories from Democrats and
of course their allies in the abusively
biased and corrupt media mob it was a
political hit job from the beginning
through and through and the president
was right it always was a witch-hunt and
as far as Muller's concerned mission
accomplished